again for the daily y representatives
for the Bud Light brand owned by
Anheuser-Busch
confirmed a brand partnership with trans
identifying active activist Dylan
Mulvaney after followers speculated the
whole thing could be an April Fool's Day
prank
now if you by the way if you were one of
those people we talked uh you know a
couple days ago about Bud Light
sponsoring Dylan Mulvaney congratulating
him on his day 365 of Womanhood oh right
no sorry girlhood because again this is
a grown adult man who is very
specifically pretending to be an
underage adolescent girl
um so congratulating him in three of day
365 of quote-unquote girlhood we talked
about that and I saw even in the
comments there are people speculating
that well no this can't be this this is
April Fool's prank this came out around
April fools it must be a big prank from
Dill Mulvaney I don't
okay this is this is still
the kind of coping that we have to put
to the side now we have to get past this
like if you're still in a position if
you still are
like it's hard for you to believe
that Bud Lights would sponsor Dylan
Mulvaney
um that just shows me that you really
haven't been paying attention and you
need the clue into reality there is
there's nothing unbelievable about it at
all
and he's a lot of the same people who
who still insist that uh maybe this
whole dilemma of anything is all one big
prank by hand he's like he's Andy
Kaufman it's a performance artist is all
one big troll
I mean this can't actually be serious
no it is serious
now it's not he's not actually a woman
obviously
but he is seriously trying to identify
as one he wants to be taken seriously as
a woman it's not a prank it's not
anything like that
and yes we live in an occult in a
culture where the the major brands are
going to line up and uh they're going to
fall prostrate to the ground and worship
at the feet of somebody like the little
Mulvaney that's where we live
a spokesperson for the company told Fox
News Anheuser-Busch works with hundreds
of influencers across Our Brands as one
of the many ways to authentically
connect with audiences across various
demographics and passion points
from time to time we produce unique
commemorative cans for fans and for
brand influencers like Dylan Mulvaney
this this commemorative can was a gift
to celebrate a personal Milestone and
it's not for sale to the General Public
so yes this was a real sponsorship
um as we should have always assumed
bulbani has partnered with multiple
National brands for advertising
campaigns on social media including
KitchenAid kind snacks wedding dress
brand Asos uh
uh MAC cosmetics and others
this guy has he really has dozens of
corporate sponsorships
because again that's the kind of culture
we live in we should probably clue into
it by now
and we need to decide like when are we
as conservatives actually going to make
a concerted and real effort
to do something about this that we
complain about it we complain about the
fact that all these corporate brands are
spitting in our face all the time and uh
they're like going out of their way to
alienate their own customer base
and then some more cope we say oh go
whoa go broke nope
I wish it was that way okay I wished it
was that way
where a company goes woke and then they
go broke that's not how it works
actually
in fact they go woke and they continue
making billions of dollars that's how
we're go woke make billions of dollars
we have the power we have the ability to
make some of these companies go broke we
could do that but we don't puretalk is
the antidote to woke wireless companies
it's proudly veteran-owned employs a
us-based customer service team and
absolutely refuses to spend money on
fake news networks here's a look at what
a future without Pure Talk would look
like for you for those of you who can't
see what's playing out on the screen
right now I am currently texting with my
producer Sean on the phone that's
serviced by one of the big three
wireless networks Sean says have you
seen the post about the left trying to
cancel you again which I reply in this
very real conversation they're always
trying to silence me and it's never
going to work because that's the kind of
thing that I would say in a text message
you know in real life I would text that
to someone when are people going to
accept that men or men and women are
women on the autocorrect changes men to
MXN and women to
w-o-m-xn if you can believe it this is
what you get with Welk Wireless
Uninvited lessons and political
correctness if there's anyone I trust to
not only give me the best service for my
money but also not try to force their
Politics on me it's pure talk no
contracts no hassle and they respect
your politics right now you can get
unlimited talk text and plenty of 5G
data for just thirty dollars a month
keep your phone keep your number or
choose from the latest iPhones and
Androids go to puretalk.com enter promo
code Walsh to save an additional 50 off
your first month that's puretalk.com
promo code Walsh puretalk is simply
smarter Wireless there is
strength in numbers
especially in a Marketplace
it's true that every major corporation
is woke they all are right
and so we can't realistically boycott
all of them
now if we did that then you wouldn't
even be able to watch this show right
now because the phone you're using or
the laptop you're using to buy it on is
made by a woke company you bought it
from a woke company you're using a woke
company's uh you know internet service
provider
um you know so
we boycott all of them and we basically
can't live in the modern world and we
also have no way to even organize any
kind of boycott like that because all
the all of the the mechanisms that we
use to more to uh to organize them are
also owned by by the woke
so yeah we can't boycott all of them
that's true
but we can pick some of them
okay this is something that we talked
about this on the backstage episode
um
on Monday
this is something the the left is
they're very good at doing this
where they they pick someone they pick a
victim and they make an example of them
okay they they pick somebody out
whether it's an individual or a company
that has offended them has crossed to
them and they say we're going to take
you down we're going to destroy you okay
you have become our personal project
not because you're the worst as far as
we're concerned but uh but just because
you're the one you're the one we've
chosen
and the left will do that and they'll
stay on it until they tear this
this victim down
now on the right we could do the same
kind of thing
and the only difference is that we're
choosing people and companies that
actually deserve it
and we'd be wielding this power for good
so yeah we can't make all the World
Companies go broke not not even close to
it but we could choose one company
that does something outrageous
to alienate and spit in the faces of
their own customer base
and we could say okay we've chosen you
and we're gonna bankrupt you because in
reality there are millions and millions
of us and you do need us to buy your
product and if we don't you're going to
suffer
okay and you got Mass layoffs in your
future uh and all the rest of it
we could do that but it takes it takes
uh organization
it takes follow through
it takes a certain you know sense of
kind of ruthlessness
because yeah if you do that you take a
company down you you know you you uh
affect their bottom line to that extent
remember people that work for the
company that aren't evil people they
just have jobs and they're going to lose
their jobs
not so you don't want to see that's it's
unfortunate
but these are these are necessary
casualties
so we have to have the willingness the
willingness we have to have the
ruthlessness we have to have the
organization the attention span and the
follow-through
and on the right we have none of that
easily distracted we move from one thing
to the next
and anytime any one of us tries to say
let's focus on this issue let's focus on
this institution let's focus on this
thing right here and try to make
something happen you're then going to
have you know 50 000 people who are also
on the right come along and say why then
this is bad yeah sure you'll do that but
then these people over here are just as
bad so what's the point of even trying
we allow ourselves to get distracted by
these losers who have no interest in
winning don't know how to win
we've got to stop
[Music]
[Applause]